il suffit pas de venir c'était le 12
juin dernier au quartier ton talent et
robert nicolas hulot ministre de la
transition écologique répond à des
habitants en colère et ben on est venu
pour dire la vérité ce phénomène nous
dépasse tous oui et vous a fait vous en
priorité
on est là à vos côtés on va essayer de
résoudre les problèmes un parrain de
cette visite ministérielle découlera une
série de mesures parmi lesquelles le
déblocage de 10 millions d'euros sur
deux ans et des déclarations chocs
l'urgence est d'organiser le ramassage
en moins de 48 heures quand les alpes
c'est chaud sur nos côtes
l'etat sera aux côtés des habitants et
des élus qui affrontent ces calamités
deux mois et demi plus tard et alors que
le ministre annonce aujourd'hui sa
démission le désarroi de la population
semble inchangée avec ma perche
étant donné que les plaques monte à la
surface lors de la marche avec la perche
j'arrive à pousser les plaques hors de
chez nous c'est pourtant non loin de là
sur la terrasse de cette maison voisine
aujourd'hui inhabités que s'est déroulée
la visite en fait en est accrue
sérieusement mise à part un ou deux
peut-être qu'ils n'ont pas été bernés
par ces paroles dites vérité binger
faire aujourd'hui nous avons vu venir
voyez vous même nicolas hulot avait
aussi annoncé un moratoire au profit des
entreprises pénalisées par l'évasion des
sargasses sirigu j'ai pu aujourd'hui
recevoir normalement sa clientèle
c'est parce qu'il a déplacé son activité
à ses frais malgré tout il enregistre
moins 30% sur son chiffre d'affaires et
de la difficulté à payer ses charges
le moratoire yatch rien parce que voilà
ce qu'on dit c'est que les délais
administratifs sont l'on sait qu'il faut
réunir tout le monde que c'est compliqué
mais nous qu'est ce qu'on vit sur le
terrain c'est nous qui sont dans une
situation compliquée si c'est pour me
dire qu'il ya des réunions ça ne sert à
rien si c'est pour me dire par contre y
aura des exonérations de cgss dire comme
hudak ondes de tva là je suis preneur
mais visiblement errigo jet n'est pas le
seul être amer la région des sargasses
qui leur pourrit la vie au quotidien et
petit à petit on s'accommode de la
gravité et on se fait complice de la
tragédie qui était en cours de gestation
on se fixe des objectifs non n'alla pas
les moyens parce qu'avec les contraintes
budgétaires
on sait très bien à l'avant ce que les
objectifs que l'on se fixe on ne pourra
pas les réaliser voilà ma vérité nicolas
hulot aura donc préféré démissionner
déçu de l'intérêt porté au plus haut
sommet du gouvernement sur des dossiers
sensibles dont les orgas ne sont qu'un
exemple parmi tant d'autres